Hello, this is Dr. Kevin Connors again with module three of your stop fighting cancer course
This is on fighting the cause
Dealing with the cause
Why we should deal with the cause why we should address the cause and try to figure out why the medical profession doesn't
even
Talk about this
Still don't know I don't have the answer to that, but we'll talk about it a little bit
So fighting the cause is an important thing it always has been an important thing to me when we started
seed cancer patients back of the 90s
It's always been important to me as a functional
doctor
Because it just makes sense to me. It's just part of my
Philosophy it's like if we don't deal with the cause then you know
How are we actually going to deal with the problem we talked about that a little bit of the band-aid approach
But that that I don't know it's just it's just as part of who I am with the with as my core
We got to deal with causes and I know that we should use that word in the plural because there's always multiple causes
But ultimately there is one thing that ends up getting inside of the cell and we need to deal with that if we can so
In order to understand that I think we have to have we have to be on the same footing in understanding what cancer is
so cancer is
Is one thing that gets inside of a cell could be an oxidative
product like some sort of oxidizing agent like a poison
Like a pesticide or a chemical or an herbicide it could be a
Bacteria or a virus or a fungus or a mold or something like that that gets inside of a cell
It affects the nucleus
So normally your cells divide most of yourselves your neurons don't and most of your cardio cells don't
readily go through this process. That's why cancer in the neurons themselves is rare and in the heart is rare
but in the the glial cells in the brain is different so long story short
Simplify the physiology here normally your cells will undergo
Reproductive cycle so your skin cells about every six to twelve weeks will reproduce another cell and
Then another six to twelve weeks that cell reproduces another cell and eventually the mother cells
You could say die off through a process of normal
Natural program cell death that is called apoptosis. That's a healthy cell death
So there's different ways that cells die
Cell death through pathology
Would be lysis so if you were poisoned you die quickly with a poison because you have massive cell
death
Massive cell lysis. So lysis of a cell is basically an exploding of a cell all the cell
Parts all the different organelles and cytoplasm inside that cell are spewed out over
Into your body you have all this waste production and through this cell death you die
So if it has to be if it's death of your of your
arterial cells your endothelial cells you could have massive explosion and and blood loss and you instantly die
Depends on what where that poison is acting on what cell line that's acting on etc
Cell lysis actually takes place when a person goes through chemotherapy
So any pathological death of a cell is called cell lysis
Normal program cell death that takes place through normal cell division of the mother cell died off is a different type of cell death called apoptosis
Totally different process the cell goes through these what are called
Blemines which is actually actually these
In pocketing of the cells and then walling off and piecing apart and literally through the use of different organelles
One of them lysis ohms inside the cell you end up
Reutilizing a lot of the cell components so it isn't an exploding of the cell and it all break it up
But you have to deal with with waste products from that cell death
It's basically a recycling of the cell material and reusing of the cell material of the body
It's a very efficient process this apoptotic process and there's different things that stimulate
Apoptosis and there's things that can hinder apoptosis
So there's actually a couple parts to
Cell line going into a cancerous production
Something gets inside the cell affects the nucleus and instead of that cell
Let's use your skin cells again instead of that cell line reproducing every six to 12 weeks now
It's reproducing every six to 12 days or worse
So if it's reproducing every six to 12 hours while that would be a very aggressive cancer
So the aggressiveness of the cancer is how fast is it reproducing?
So the aggressiveness of the cancer is how fast is that rate of replication?
And then what also happens in a cancer cell mass is that the mother cells are not going through apoptosis
So they are slightly deformed. They look different on a slide
They're not healthy normal cells. They're rapidly reproducing and they're not dying
So they're not going through lysis. They're not going through apoptosis
So the purpose of chemotherapy chemotherapy is a poison and oxidizing agent that
Hopefully because this rapidly growing cell mass is
more metabolically active
It's you could say hungrier. Now this hungrier cell mass will uptake the poison faster than a healthy cell
Which isn't quite as hungry because it's not as metabolically active
So the idea of chemotherapy is that since the cancer is hungrier, it's gonna take up the poison more readily and
The poison will kill the cells. Well, of course some of the healthy cells are gonna take up the poison to and they could die as well
Of course, they're healthier so the chance of them dying is a little bit less
That's the idea of chemotherapy and in general it can work
But a person could have ill effects of it because you have death of healthy cells and
Etc. There's other things so let's talk isn't about chemotherapy, but that's the idea if we understand what cancer is
We can understand why it can be important to address the cause
And I've said in other videos that
Wow, they do all this research on what causes cancer, you know, charcoals foods to newspaper ink to
Pesticides and herbicides and everything, but then once a person is diagnosed with cancer and if they're astute enough to go
Well, Mr. Dr. oncologist what's the cause of my cancer?
Usually they get a black sterile. Well, we just don't know or you just have bad luck or you have bad genes or whatever it is
You know, it's very rare that we ever hear anybody
Was told that they have a certain cause for their cancer unless they have a bronchagine defect and then it's
Splayed on genetics or they have positive HPV or something with uterine or
Or some sort of sort of vaginal cancer it is blamed on that, but
Typically cause is never investigated and partly because
They don't really have a treat, but that's not really part of the protocol understand practice of medicine good and bad
Is that really the protocols in the practice of medicine called the standards of care
Really written by the pharmaceutical industry because they have a quote-unquote treatment for it
So when there's no treatment for
Pesticide exposure causing the cancer while we don't deal with that so that that just doesn't exist in their mind and
That's unfortunate. So understand
What you talk about cause you really have to understand what cancer is something got inside that cell
affected the nucleus and it could be a plethora of different things got inside the cell affected the nucleus now
That cell line is going through rapid replication and it's not going through a poptosis
Now here's a little side note when women especially with cancers that are
ER positive PR positive or her two positive what does that actually mean does that mean
Estergins are the cause of the cancer therefore dropping estrogen down to nothing with the rheumatase inhibitor type drugs is
Going to cure the cancer. Well
No
Estrogen is not the cause of the cancer estrogen did it get inside the cell and cause the cell to go through rapid replication
So what we're thinking about cause we're talking about what affected the nucleus to go into rapid replication?
Well, we're talking about hormone positive cancers. That is talking about what's
Hinderine apoptosis
So you have different so a cell goes through normal program cell death apoptosis because of an internal factor
Internal to the cell and an external factor external to the cell the external factor has to do with the cell membrane
So your cell membranes have thousands of different receptors on those membranes that do different things
On the cell membranes you have what are called apoptotic receptors
One of the types of apoptotic receptors is called an et al receptor that bad estergins quote-unquote bad end estergins can
Attached to that receptor and block apoptosis
So when a person is ER positive
Hurt too positive or PR positive it's shown via
Investigation in testing in a laboratory that that person's cells cancer cells
have
Those bad estergins attached to those receptors block eat apoptosis. It's not the cause of the cancer
but it is causing a decrease in apoptotic
Function so the cell isn't going through normal program cell death so decreasing
Bad estergins would be extremely helpful in overcoming cancer with these people now do you need to go on a
Medical drug apoptotic
um
Hormone blocker
Well, that's questionable there are some natural hormone blockers out there
I list them in my book in detail that you could look at an investigate and start utilizing those you could even use those if you are
Going to go on an aerobatic inhibitor medical drug now a lot of women don't like those drugs a lot of men with prostate cancer
Don't like energy deprivation therapy
You can reduce these
Bad hormones quote-unquote the ones that attach to those receptors
Through natural means never going to be as
Good quote-unquote as if you took the drug and completely wiped out all your hormones
Um, but there's a lot of side effects of that and negative is of that too that a lot of men and women don't like so
Look at that investigate that
But that's not fixing the cause it's fixing part of the cause you could say it's affecting
You know the hindrance of apoptosis, but it's not
blocking the
replication piece
Hopefully that wasn't too much information, but so understanding cancer helps us understand why we want to look at cause
So why does cancer continue to grow? I thought my immune system was supposed to knock down this cancer and destroy it
Is it because I have an unhealthy immune system? Is that why it's continuing to grow?
Well, we talked about one possible reason why it's continuing to grow in that apoptosis is not taking place because of possible hormone interaction
But let's say I have a cancer that isn't hormone related. So that's not the reason
Well, remember cancer is your old cells
So it is self tissue
Now normally in self tissue your immune system doesn't attack self tissue. Otherwise, we'd all be dead
So self tissue um is blocked
Is your immune system is blocked from attacking self tissue because your T cells what are your natural killer cells
Your immune cells have this little receptor on it that your self tissue cells attached to that receptor and turn off
T cell attack to self tissue. That's how self tissue
Is preserved or protected from your own immune system and the immune system then that's the
The smart pack of the immune system so the immune system will then just attack
Um, uh, things that are not self tissue your immune system is not supposed to get rid of pesticides and herbicides and chemicals and heavy metals
Your immune system gets rid of bacteria and viruses and mold and funguses and biotoxins
So your immune system kills biotoxins and then your detoxification process gets rid of heavy metals and poisons and pesticides and such
And that's part of the problem with cancer is that
Is that we are exposed to way more poisons and toxins and chemicals than our ancestors wherever exposed to
And it can overwhelm our liver and by overwhelming our liver
Then these things get shunted to the cells and and to the tissues and get
Basically stored inside the cells and that is a major cause of cancer as all these poisons that we're exposed to that are stored in the cell
Could have been something you're supposed to at six years old and has been stored in the cell for 50 years now
And now just happens to affect the nucleus. It is causing
this rapid replication. So
Get it wide as cancer keep growing well
Part of the reason is is that cancer is your own cells
So because it's your own cells your immune system isn't attacking it
Secondly, uh, cancer keeps growing because of possible hormone involvement blockied apoptosis
Thirdly has to do with your immune response. So lots of things that decrease my immune response
Will cause the cancer to uptick we're seeing in the last few years with this advent of this
Quotal-quote virus which is odd because most viral exposures
Um actually cause an immune response to uptick. So when you have a bacterial infection or you have a viral infection
You'll end up with an increased white blood cell count
That's kind of how you know you have a bacterial infection or some sort of biotoxin because you have it acutely
spiked white blood cell count
um, but this
um, so quote unquote virus that is in it in
uh
Society at the present time is causing a downtick of the immune response which is quite odd when makes you a question
Whether there's some man-made interference of this thing
um, and that downtick is causing a huge spike in cancers
So um, how is it causing a huge spike in cancers? Well at least one thing at least one piece of the cause is it's causing a downtick in the immune response
So the truth is is that all of us have
Some cancer cells growing in us and what's keeping them at bay is when they get to a certain size our immune system even though they
They tend to turn off against self-tissue when it gets to a certain size your immune system should attack it and kill it
If my immune system is suppressed for any reason going through a horrible financial time
I'm going through a very difficult time with my children or my spouse or my work environment
My stress is there so stress
Increased sympathetic response
decreases my immune system response and
Now my immune system is downticked if I have exposure to this weird type of virus that's causing a decrease in my immune response
Or if I have a chronic infection or chronic inflammatory response or maybe I'm exposed to a lot of poisons in my workspace
So I have a decreased immune response because my body's dealing with just an overwhelm of whatever's going on
There are hundreds of different reasons why
But if my immune system is suppressed in any way, I'm going to give an advantage to cancer growing and that is a problem
So why does it metastasize?
So cancer as it gets larger and larger and larger
Is giving off what are called circulating tuber cells there are also called cancer stem cells
So that cancer circulating tuber cell breaks off and is going to go into the bloodstream
Circulate through the bloodstream
Get across the epithelial lining of the bloodstream get into another tissue somewhere else and look for a place to set up
Home and raise a family
And once it starts replicating there, now we have metastasis
So while that single cell that single circulating tuber cell is going through the bloodstream
It's not yet rapidly replicating
And this is a problem when you're doing chemotherapy remember I said chemotherapy is going to be more attracted to
highly metabolic tissue
So when the cancer is growing and replicating and getting larger, it's very hungry
So it's going to gobble up more of the chemotherapy than healthy cells
But the catch 22 is everybody has circulating tuber cells
So personally do not put your faith in a circulating tuber cell lab
Because that will only pick up circulated tuber cells in that little blood sample that you collected
But your circulated tumor cells are in the blood and in the tissue
You could never find out how many circulated tumor cells you have in the tissue
so
circulated tumor cells are not yet
rapidly replicating so they're not yet highly metabolic
So they haven't started the replication phase
And which is setting up pulmonary and a family in another tissue
So they're not going to be so affected by the chemotherapy
So chemotherapy might effectively reduce the size of a primary tumor
But they really do nothing to kill circulated tumor cells
And the other negative chemotherapy not to knock on that
Because it could be very beneficial for a lot of people
But it decreases your immune response
Because chemotherapy is going to be attracted to rapidly replicating or highly metabolic activity
And different cell lines are more highly metabolic
Your hair follicles are more highly metabolic cell line
That's why people lose their hair
When they do chemotherapy because chemotherapy is attracted to more highly metabolic cell lines
Well, so as your immune system your immune system is more highly metabolic
So chemotherapy is going to be attracted to that
And that's what knocks down your immune response
And it's like oh, damn it, I thought I needed a immune response in order to kill my cancer
Well, you do
Well, that's the catch 22 of chemotherapy
So you better be doing a lot of other immune stimulation
So that's where if you're going to do standards of care
You better be doing a lot of alternative things too to help build up your body
So I'm not against doing chemotherapy
If that's the direction that God is leading you
But you better be doing some other things as well
So cancer metastasizes by getting giving off
Circulating tumor cells that is just looking for another place to grow
And different cancers tend to metastasize to different areas
Partly because of location
Breast cancer tends to metastasize to the lung and the brain and the liver
Whereas prostate cancer tends to metastasize to the bones and the pelvis and the lumbar spine
The abdominal cavity
Well, that makes sense because that's kind of the location of where it's at
So
We need to look for that as well and treat that
That's why
Make sure you're stimulated your immune response with whatever approach you're taking
So this is where why finding the cause helps because if you're cleaning up the environment
If you're trying to deal with the pesticides, the toxins, the
heavy metal
Poisony that you may have exposed to for the last 30 years or
Or biotoxins that you've been exposed to
You're you're going to help prevent
um
That um metastasis to occur so we can't stop the reason why the cancers there in the first place by magically waving a wand over fixing the cause
But you can help reduce metastasis and that's really the goal
It's 90 some percent of the people who pass away from cancer is because of the metastasis
Not the primary tumor so we want to do everything we can
To help block that there's other things that we can do to help
Keylate and grab on to circulated to ourselves and I write a lot about that in my book as well
You want to be active with that as well
So how do we address the cause?
Well how you could address the cause if you're not a patient of ours is to read my book
Look at my detoxification piece
Very important and start dealing with possible causes that you were exposed to in your life
um
And that's the way to do it you have to look at it holistically as much as possible
We do a cheek swab and we do some specific testing, but I know
This whole series is addressed to people who can't do that come to us and have that procedure done
So for what you need to do is you need to be lucky at my seven phases of detoxification book
I give a ton of information
Three um that you could download and look at and utilize different things to help your body getting rid of
Poisons and toxins and biotoxins in your body and stay as clean as possible because that's really the key
You're never going to be able to not have any toxins in your body
Detoxification is a lifelong process
Um, I talk to people every day that go well am I going to do a detox?
Um, I don't even like using those words because you're not going to do a detox if you're not detoxing
You're going to die
So you are detoxing so you're still alive talking to me you are detoxing
We just need to help the process
We need to to
Accelerate the process heal the process. That's what the next module we're going to talk about is is the art of detoxification
Understanding those phases because that is so so key
So you don't do a box detox that you're going to do for two weeks and now you're healthy and clean
That's absolutely ridiculous
You're going to you're going to promote that process on a daily basis because you're being poisoned constantly
Even if you're eating organic and doing everything possible right you're still being exposed to poisons and you're still being
Toxified so we want to constantly be supporting your organs of detoxification
So you could help clean that out constantly so we'll go into depth of that so don't worry
Um, all right, so I hope I didn't talk too fast
Maybe I have to listen to this again. I tend to ramble. I apologize. Hopefully this is a blessing to you
I really wanted to be so all right. We'll get into module four just a second
Um stick with us and walk you through this process. Thanks so much